hey everybody and welcome to a bumping
wild ride with stevo we're bumping and
grinding and hipping and hopping just
bouncing i'm telling you this one's the
one it's juicy it's it's it's
dollar signs man we are talking money
dude what's this man earn
dude he's candid about the business of
no jumper and he's candid about the
business of his wiener right i'm telling
you the guy is really really using his
wiener he's using it well and i applaud
him we had a wonderful conversation and
let me point out
that
uh today for the first time someone said
hey man stevo looks like you've you've
lost weight you look really good and
gosh dang darn it i've been trying my
butt off you know i feel like taking off
my shirt right now i look so good and
you know the secret is dude it's all
about the diet man i'm really reeling in
my diet
and i'm not compromising anything about
my nutrition because i got my athletic
greens it's comprehensive
convenient daily nutrition in just one
pack man you get everything that you
need and by everything that you need i
mean maybe more than you even need we're
talking about
75 different
vitamins minerals whole whole
food-sourced superfoods
adaptogens probiotics this stuff
rearranges your body in the best way it
makes your brain work better because
it's
good for your brain and your thinking
you're going to be smarter it
it makes your gut health better your
digestion it's get it's filling in all
the gaps in your diet and let me tell
you it's delicious i use it every
morning and hey man
i'm glowing it just shows it just shows
how well i'm taking care of myself and i
want you to enjoy those of you who are
watching this on youtube how good i look
and i want you to also go to
athleticgreens.com
stevo to get five of these comprehensive
convenient daily nutrition packs plus
an entire year's supply of immune
boosting vitamin d
with your first purchase if you go to
athleticgreens.com
stevo it's a lifestyle it's health it's
wellness
and you deserve it for yourself so one
more time go to
athleticgreens.com to enjoy this with
your first purchase and let's get into
it
all right we're recording we went orange
for the basketball oh nice hell yeah is
that a good call i like it yeah all
right sweet
ladies and gentlemen adam 22
stevo
yeah dude so we've just done the no
jumper podcast yes
and uh i thought it was pretty sweet i
had a good time yeah yeah yeah we only
had like an hour 10 hour 20 so i had to
kind of just like
skim through a couple of random topics
and you know right talk about sobriety
talk about me being a fan in the early
days that kind of stuff yeah dude um i
feel like we we got a little bit well
what kind of schedule do you keep
because you have like she said there's
like seven interviews going in and out
of here today yeah so busy well i have
other hosts doing a lot of the
interviews you know and then like i have
another like a porn podcast that i do
with my girl so i have to go shoot some
episodes of that after this but i mean a
lot of times honestly i'll have like
three four or five interviews in a day
just because like my schedule's kind of
so all over the place that sometimes
i'll have to like just be like all right
[ __ ] i'm doing everything monday
right like i'm leaving tuesday i'm doing
five interviews monday like i just have
to hammer it out and it kind of sucks
because it's like you kind of feel like
you can't do anything else with your
brain during that like you're just a
podcast machine but i can go to the
extreme with it and then kind of just
have to chill after
it's insane dude like um
yesterday i went to um
this place good mythical morning have
you ever heard of that no it's got 17
million subscribers on youtube why it's
uh like the biggest most watched daily
show on youtube
and and i was unaware of it i show up
again yeah i show up at their
headquarters it's like the biggest
[ __ ]
like
and then the the lady's like i'm the
executive producer here's the show
runner like this
and i'm like damn and then they're only
a youtube channel wow like like what the
digital
[ __ ]
revolution has brought about it's insane
like uh
like then like my publicist is making a
bigger deal out of this good mythical
morning youtube thing
than like some late night
i gotta check that out that's crazy but
yeah no for sure
and it was hilarious because when i
started it was just like
i want to interview people i want to
like see how
how much i can do how far i can take
this how big of a you know celebrities i
can manage to interview or whatever and
then to see the game change so much that
like we have like eight different hosts
doing interviews
you know like just the fact that we were
able to buy this [ __ ] big ass
building that i wish we were in right
now so i could be showing you it just to
do more podcasts out it was pretty crazy
like i'm officially at the point in
podcasting where everything i'm doing
now is stuff that i never could have
imagined doing when i started which is
pretty cool for sure
um
now when uh no jumper started like i
watched like i i typed in adam 22
documentary
on youtube to try and try and get some
background on you i wonder if there's
anything good it's pretty funny like uh
like like there's a some clown
but he's like uh
because of your
they're talking about like your dad
bill clinton
and he's like clearly he's uh
like what
the freemasons whatever like
this guy said in this video he says
everybody knows that every president has
always just been a puppet for the
freemasons
that's a good example like when i
started podcasting i did not know that
the end result would be people like
making up theories about me being in a
secretive society for years right that's
that's a twist that i never could have
predicted i mean and
until you've got people like
making
documentaries trying to tear you down
you you know you haven't made it
someone uh dj academics actually told me
years ago he said you're not really
famous until you have other famous
people publicly hating on you there you
go and that is a pretty big standard
because a lot of famous people tend to
keep their mouths shut about other
famous people that they don't like you
know so if you get to the point where
people are actually [ __ ] on you
publicly
and they're they have something to lose
there it's not like you know a bunch of
troll accounts [ __ ] on you that is a
different level of fame right
as soon as this uh this video said it
was start talking about freemasons and
then puppets of
i i turned it off immediately and and it
didn't have any views
um but but one thing i saw it was
talking about um how no jumper
was started what like
you didn't start the actual no jumper
thing so i did i it was kind of like a
confusion basically there's this like
guy who's tried to like take credit for
starting it but the truth is is that
before no drummer was a youtube channel
i had the url and it was basically an
idea that we were going to start this
like rap blog right like we were just
going to have articles about rap and
stuff like that and i started it but
there was this dude that i had basically
like writing articles for free for the
article for the site right and uh he did
that for like a couple months maybe like
one month and then he just dipped out
and just like stopped responding to me
and so that project was like really
really short-lived and it did get you
know
2011.
yeah 2011 sounds about right yeah so
that was like super short-lived um but
then a couple years later i hit that
dude up like i guess he had hit me up
after that after he went dark on me and
i basically was like yo you remember the
no jumper url i was thinking of using it
for a youtube channel because i want to
start interviewing rappers so i told the
dude and he said yeah like that's cool
you should do that but then he probably
didn't expect it to get really really
really big
yeah well then he starts just talking
[ __ ] because he wants to act as if he
was somehow involved in no jumper
blowing up when in reality i haven't
even spoken to this guy since i started
the youtube channel but that got kind of
like exaggerated where people decided
that they wanted to act like that dude
had some involvement in my success when
in reality he was an unpaid intern
for a prior business that had the same
name
but was completely removed from you know
it was it's like people just cook up
these weird ass theories because the
truth is is to that kid like writing a
couple blog posts for this prior version
of no jumper was like a big deal
and he doesn't want to let that go and
it hurts him that
jumper is a totally different thing i i
didn't like get a sense that there was
anything controversial about it oh no
it's just weird because people like
think that they think like they they
read that sentence like i've had a lot
of different people say that to me and
it's like dude i started this and i was
the only person even doing content on
this channel for the first couple years
i had a couple of co-hosts here and
there and only the last couple years has
we actually brought on
other hosts that are actually doing
podcasts and stuff it was like a one-man
operation besides like one employee for
a long ass time right and uh so now it's
like a like a network
kind of yeah like i don't know how it
got to that point where like i always
had that idea that i wanted to bring
people on and then there's this dude a.d
who's a like a rapper and he's from
compton and he i just had known him
thought he seemed like he had a cool
personality and stuff and and right when
the coronavirus [ __ ] hit i was just like
bro like around that time i was like you
should you know do some news we're
trying to start this news thing or we're
going to try to do some podcasts or
whatever with different hosts and we
just started [ __ ] with him and the
fans started [ __ ] with him and we
just kind of we built that up and then
after that like a lot more hosts we just
kind of started to figure out how to
actually just do consistent content with
people the people we're feeling and uh
yeah at this point now we're just trying
to take it
keep keep going with it like i i could
almost see us being like a bar stool but
for like hip hop culture type thing
right
it's like
i went to marshall recently and i was
like oh this is like
my [ __ ] but probably like 30 times
bigger but it's kind of like my [ __ ]
yeah you should have a [ __ ] matt host a
segment
we thought about it it's very political
out here with that guy with him yeah
just because he's like such a crazy ass
gang banger it's like there's there's
there's a line between like
a gang member somebody who like is in a
gang but is not out here just talking
crazy [ __ ] about everybody else there's
another but [ __ ] mack is like a
different level where he's extremely
aggressive and and you know it creates a
lot of problems with other hosts on the
network and stuff i remember seeing like
snoop dogg come out with a new
album and [ __ ] it had i mean years ago
now but
but uh
probably not ten years ago and he was
talking about like blue handkerchief
coming out of my back pocket and i
didn't even know he was a crit before
that yeah no i do i didn't know there
was a [ __ ] before that but
but i remember thinking that
my
initial just sort of gut reaction was
like man snoop you've come so far like
you don't need to be talking about blue
handkerchieves
like does that is that a fair thought
nah cause i think somebody like snoop
dogg like like gang banging is whatever
you make of it right like like you could
be a [ __ ] and you could be literally
like going out and trying to shoot your
enemies every day or you could be a 40
year old dude who's like yeah i was a
[ __ ] coming up or even like i know dudes
are young
guys who are like clearly
identified with a certain neighborhood
or whatever and it's not some negative
thing it's not like they've got to fight
people or shoot people or whatever now
the reality is is for like most young
people that there are a lot of negative
consequences that come from it but
somebody like snoop i mean even at the
super bowl
he's throwing up [ __ ] c's at the at
the at the super bowl you know like
the version of [ __ ] that he's pushing is
not a negative one it's it's just love
for his community so he's like uh a
hell's angel that's not the one percent
exactly where it's like he he
appreciates the culture and he respects
it and he has love for it but it's not
like he's endorsing any of the
negativity that comes with it you know
all right that's how i would think of it
at least and and then there's six nine
i think you got to be a pretty funny guy
for people to start cracking up like
that just because somebody said your
name and what can i say six nine
hilarious we have a good laugh about him
snitching and stuff
but one thing i do not joke about is my
rest man my night's sleep i mean dude
let me ask you how disgusting is your
mattress be honest and how well are you
sleeping because i've got the answer
i've got a great deal for you from helix
sleep.com
helix will
get you a personalized tailored mattress
for you by giving you this
sleep quiz you fill it out and then they
will match you with the perfect mattress
they've got 14 different types of
mattress luxury mattresses mattress for
big and tall mattress just for kids
and
when you order this personalized
mattress it comes straight to your door
free of charge how about that and on top
of that they give you a 100 night
free trial period meaning that if you
don't love your mattress for a full 100
nights you can send it back for a
complete refund i'm telling you but
there's no way you're going to send it
back because you're going to love it
because it's going to be the mattress
for you these are the sleep pros and if
you go to helixsleep.com
then they're gonna give you up to 200
off of any mattress that you choose
plus two free pillows and i'm telling
you that they're
cruelty free
no feathers pillows are my favorite
pillows in the whole wide world helix
sleep.com baby get yourself a new
mattress it's time to just throw away
that old disgusting one it's time to
sleep better and telling you one more
time go to helix sleep.com
stevo for up to 200 off your mattress
plus two free pillows shipped straight
to your door free of charge and no risk
100 night
come on jump on it helix sleep.com stevo
now let's laugh at 6 9.
did you watch the documentary about 6 9
on hulu yeah i've had the pleasure of
watching three six nine documentaries
because they interviewed me for all
three oh wow so i kind of wanted to see
all three and i'll be honest with you
though
documentary making has come so far
because they managed to each documentary
managed to tell his story in such a
different way with using different
characters telling the story valid
versions of it yeah they're all pretty
valid yeah i was actually it made me
learn a lot about documentary making
because i saw all the different routes
that they were able to go with that
subject matter you know you know like my
take i only watched the one i believe it
was on hulu and it was like daniel
hernandez or whatever and um i remember
my takeaway being like you know
the only thing that really uh i think
kind of made him look bad was just at
the very end like with his baby mama
saying like about like kind of not being
there for the kid
oh man she said crazy [ __ ] about him
like she said that he beat her and raped
her and all this wow
which
surprisingly kind of went under the
radar like didn't really get that much
attention because i feel like people had
already decided that they thought he was
a bad guy and then she came out with
like
a really [ __ ] up story about all how
[ __ ] up he was to her and i felt like
people didn't really pay that much
attention to it which is i mean she's
like a really great person from my
perspective too and like yeah i mean he
really is kind of like the super villain
of rap because he's just kind of burnt
everybody
along the way
it's crazy dude i mean it's it's crazy
and like we were talked on your podcast
about
people who get caught up in
maintaining like the appearance of super
success and just being flashy with cars
and money and and everything but then
they fall off
and they still need to try to maintain
this appearance but it's beyond their
means to do so you've got to believe
that
that's kind of the boat he's in
like paying taxes you know a lot of
those people don't pay taxes for three
four years like on tmz this was this has
got to be the most uncomfortable look
like on tmz he's he's uh trying to
reconcile
like having like this like
blocks of cash and saying this is
millions of dollars this is how i live
this is my lifestyle i'm rich i'm rich i
got i got houses on my arms like yeah
what's the house 250
uh in florida [ __ ]
that'll give you a lot of the way there
right yeah
80 in florida but but meanwhile while
he's saying this i'm rich this is my
lifestyle this is real
like he's saying to the judge in a
lawsuit situation that he's broke and
doesn't have any money and then he's
talking to tmz with harvey levin and
saying look man like i'm an entertainer
so it's like so you're you're well
didn't 50 cent do that too
i was in that same exact situation but
the thing about 69 is that he
will come out and make songs talking
[ __ ] about other rappers who are actual
like real deal gang members who like are
on some crazy [ __ ] that we could not
even imagine how much murder and
bloodshed they've seen both their
enemies getting killed and their family
getting killed and then meanwhile six
nine will be calling them out trying to
provoke them to do something violent and
then also meanwhile i mean he is a
federal witness he is required by law to
tell the feds everything that they want
to know and he's still he's so addicted
to the idea of being perceived as a
gangster that he's out here like really
trying to pretend that while also having
to stay in consistent communication with
the fbi is that something that's an
ongoing thing yeah yeah i think he has
to check in like like and that's why i
think people are so people don't want to
be for them he he's like look how [ __ ]
hip-hop is nobody has killed me
and then everybody who actually kills
people is like i'm not killing you you
got the [ __ ] the feds in your back
pocket like any kind of beef that we
start with you is gonna be reiterated to
them right yeah he's probably being
watched 24 7. everything's tapped i mean
there's got to be like no precedent for
like someone who's turned like a
states witness or whatever federal
informant and like normally you go into
like a witness protection program but
this [ __ ] guy they tried to get him
to do that and he didn't even want to
have personal security and that's why
like there's a video of him going into a
gas station and he's just buying
something you could tell he's like alone
or like maybe there's a girl in the car
and he's got a bag that he's wearing
right here and he's got his hand in it
like you could tell he's holding his gun
while he's going in the 7-eleven to buy
a [ __ ] soda
and it's like he's got some guy like
filming him talking [ __ ] in the gas
station and it's like that's the reality
of his life is that he's got to be ready
to [ __ ] he's either got a roll of
security all the time or he's got to be
ready to shoot somebody at any time
right and then
like you can't afford security anymore
because like no one will [ __ ] with you
and you're not making money yeah that's
like one of the great mysteries because
i mean i i know he could go play shows
overseas and stuff and make [ __ ] loads
of money but then i also like yeah i'm
pretty sure his financial situation is
like ridiculously expensive and he has
all these legal situations i don't know
dude it's it's it's not um
the [ __ ] uh
i said
yeah it's just so fascinating um what
what was he just put out a song recently
and it was like pretty good right
it didn't do that well nobody was like
riding on the car through new york like
on top of it yeah i mean it felt like it
was kind of attached to like an energy
drink somehow yeah he started an energy
drink and an nft collection called gna
okay the nft collection did pretty good
i think right i would really doubt that
i'm going to be honest with you like
these are not like having a good
reputation it's not a great market right
now and i think especially if you're a
rapper pushing an nft that the fans are
even more turned off because there was a
while there where everybody was trying
to get me to do a [ __ ] nft collection
and trying to pay me like let me give
you 40 grand to say that you're [ __ ]
with my nft
and i'm just like it took me a while to
understand and then by the time i really
fully understood i was like i'm glad
that i said no to almost all of this i
might i might have posted a couple of
them but i sold one really like uh not
like backing anybody else's nftc i just
created one and put it on a thing right
sold it for what at the time i write for
one which at the time was like 3 000
bucks
and
so you set up like a crypto wallet kind
of a thing right and and uh
did the
password is like a series of words and
everything you know i write it down on a
[ __ ] box you lost it yeah
my editor threw it away
into my my i'm like dude you [ __ ] me
you threw away my east he goes dude i'll
wait until it crashes i'll pay back
hilarious
i interviewed a girl who made like
hundreds of thousands of dollars of
farting into jars and selling it
so she would uh she would sit around all
day drinking protein shakes and then
just like farting like just holding
these jars to her ass and i think she
would put like a i forget if it was a
cotton ball or something to help like
keep the fart smell in the jar and she
sold so many of these but she said she
made herself sick from all the protein
shakes she had to go to the hospital so
then she started selling fart jar nfts
right
and i guess she made a lot of money
selling those all these thirsty ass
dudes too and like in the interview
she's like i have i've created this
custom fart jar nft for you and it was
like customized i think i had a 22 on it
from from me or whatever and then after
she just kept hitting me up like hey can
you like send me your your crypto wallet
your open seas whatever so i can send
you this fart jar
nft and i i don't think i ever gave her
the information so i i never redeemed it
so if it does end up being very valuable
which it will not then
i will have missed out or she will own
me here's the thing dude that [ __ ]
nft
was structured such that every time it
gets resold
i get 10
of that sale and i think it's been
resold like a [ __ ] ton of times i think
that uh it's crazy
i don't even get any of it because
you're locked out of the whole ecosystem
i don't even want to know i mean part of
me thinks like
it's poetic and and uh kind of beautiful
that like
that that was my one little experience
with crypto
and like
scott loves crypto i think it's the
future i think so too i was actually
thinking like i want to buy like a
couple hundred grand worth of bitcoin
right now i mean dude do you ever think
about like doing porn in the metaverse
right before crypto crash i had this
metaverse company hitting me up trying
to pay me a [ __ ] load of money like many
millions of dollars to basically do
metaverse porn with my girl and other
guests or whatever and at first
i'm like you know this sounds stupid as
[ __ ] and then they keep stressing i'm
like all right you know if this is how
much it's going to pay i will take some
days out of my life to film this
metabolism sure we're all getting a
threesome yeah
well but with like little probes all
over your body and like a green screen
background and all this weird [ __ ] that
we're gonna have to do for the metaverse
thing i think right but then crypto
crash and then they just stopped
emailing me and i was i was kind of
relieved yeah we have a buddy who's uh
close by i'm not gonna say his name but
because he he has the oculus and i'm
like
i'm like you ever watched porno on the
oculus he's like dude watching porn on
the oculus and you get you had like like
that dick sucking machine he's like it's
the best experience of all time how do i
not know about this dick sucking machine
yeah like i guess it's like just
i don't know you put it over your dick
it's just like
it's like a little machine that just
[ __ ] i want like a car wash
for my dick like like with little like
brushes and like soap and
yeah yeah you could do something like
that because i mean i i haven't been in
the porn metaverse but my friend a.d he
was saying he went in it and i was like
how was it and he goes it was weird i
had a white dick
he's like he's like looking down at like
a white dick for the first time in his
life in the metaverse which i guess he
maybe just didn't update the shade if
you can do that but yeah that's amazing
i i don't know dude like i i i refuse to
like jerk off with lube or like i i
didn't even like watch porn when i would
jerk off for the longest time i would
just jerk off to my memories and now i
now i watch porn more often i i i had to
stop porn man oh yeah yeah mr addicted
to everything
that's exactly right i haven't i haven't
busted a nut in 130 days
you're into all this [ __ ] that these
kids like
i'm in the crypto edging
retention that's sick no i i just got
into therapy for like like severe
intimacy [ __ ]
and so they're like you should abstain
you know for a certain period of time to
like rewire stuff and then like
they have
like 60 days i'm like so could i bust a
nut again and they're like no because
you asked and i'm like
what and then i haven't asked and i'm on
like 130 days and i'm just like dude
like i want to ask then i don't want
them to be like you're not ready because
yeah you haven't had a wet dream [ __ ] no
i used to have wet dreams before i
figured out how to jerk off when i was a
kid i got on my hands and knees like
three days ago and prayed for a wet
dream
i was like dude please just let me just
have a relief i figured out jacking off
way before any goo came out
yeah i was such a late bloomer i didn't
figure it out until i was like 13 or 14.
oh yeah dude i had like um like 12 when
i first jerked off
i did we had this shower that like oh
like there was like a bathroom that
opened up to the backyard and the
swimming pool and the shower had uh like
a foot faucet
to like wash your feet so i i somehow
just figured out that if i crawled
underneath the foot faucet and put my
wiener under there like uh there was rad
did you have a bathtub
yeah but but it's tough to to crawl
under and and
get your wiener under under that faucet
this is this was just somehow worked
really well so i would like be under
that [ __ ] thing
you said you jerked off nine times in
one day i definitely [ __ ] climaxed
with my wiener under that faucet nine
times in one afternoon wow in seventh
grade i've done like five and i thought
that was pretty extreme
yeah but i've only banged five times in
a day i've never even considered
masturbating that many times yeah but
when i when i masturbate like the other
day i jerked off twice before i left the
house and to me like
it felt like i just smoked a bunch of
cigarettes because i don't smoke
cigarettes but like
sometimes
if i do it means i'm like kind of in a
degenerate state like the other like
recently i only got like two hours sleep
and i had a full day of interviews and i
[ __ ] bought a pack of cigarettes so i
was just smoking them because it's like
somehow that feels right to me when i'm
like burning the candle at both ends
yeah and that's how i kind of feel about
jerking off like it's like it's like
maintenance in a way because it makes me
like chill the [ __ ] out but then also if
you do it too much it's kind of like
it's just like weird habitual behavior
of like i'm gonna make myself
calm down by doing this stupid thing to
myself over and over i don't know right
you just leave the house your skin's all
oily and you just have shame i don't
even like doing with how do i boil my
dick ups so realistically i might have
some chafing if i were to beat it that
many times
yeah or i could just find some oil
so you and your girl do porn together
yeah well how about that for a direct
and
fast response he does porn with this
girl and that's crazy to me man i know
that i never could have done porn
but now that i've discovered bluetooth
tablets i wonder if
that could have changed the game for me
it certainly has changed the game for me
in my relationship with my girl lux
i mean i've never failed to
deliver the dong for lux when i chew up
my bluetooth tablets which are of course
tablets which contain the same active
ingredient as both viagra and cialis
except cost only a fraction of the price
when i chew up my tablets my tongue is
blue when i show my blue tongue two
lucks she screams audibly in excitement
because she knows that means i have just
declared war on her vagina with my rock
hard boner because that's what's gonna
happen it's gonna be a war when i
take my bluetooth tablets about 30
minutes later i'm just invincible and is
it fun yeah it's a lot of fun and do you
need a prescription yeah but when you go
to bluechew.com and consult with their
online medical providers it is so fast
so easy requires no trip to a doctor's
office you're just up and running and
the tablets are in the mail and get this
if you use the promo code stevo
bluechew.com they will give you an
entire month's supply of bluechew
tablets absolutely for free all you have
to pay is five dollars for shipping let
that sink in for a moment
five dollars for shipping is all it's
going to cost you for an entire month's
supply of chew tablets
what that means is that an entire month
of just
unbelievable boners
is in store for you if you go to
bluetooth.com and use the promo code
stevo you are insane if you have not
tried this so jump on it right now and
one more time bluetooth.com promo code
stevo and let's jump into this porn talk
so your girl
does porn so she does porn just with me
and uh she mostly just does the only fan
[ __ ] and then we have a show together
called plug talk available at
onlyplugtalk.com where basically we
interview chicks and then we bang them
together and that's what i'm doing right
after this wow dude
today yes do you know who you're going
to bone i do
uh can you say the name it's like little
quiche
dude that's pretty impressive i mean
that's like
an open relationship well but not really
because like i don't [ __ ] with other
girls in my regular life she doesn't
[ __ ] with other guys but we do stuff
with other girls on camera so besides
the content we have a normal monogamous
relationship
if you have to like and only fans get to
like like cut next scene or is it just
because it's you're going to get into
the mode you just keep going you kind of
have that decision to make in general
when you're making porn is like do you
want to
do you want to make it all about getting
the best possible image where you
actually like frame up every single shot
like the way they're doing a movie and
where you're thinking about the lighting
and you're thinking about like exactly
like making the shot just look as good
as possible or the way we tend to do it
more is like let's just actually have
fun let's make this like closer to us
actually just having a threesome and
maybe every single shot doesn't look
perfect because the cameraman is
capturing you know one of the girls
[ __ ] waddling over to [ __ ] get
into a different position or whatever
but we we try to like err on the side of
it being more real you know that makes
sense to me yeah how did you
start that conversation like what was
the why'd you do it so you know vitaly
yeah vitali do you have one recently no
he he was on roman atwood's place right
yeah he's done a bunch recently so
vitaly i've interviewed and stuff and he
when did you interview vitaly maybe
three years ago or something but it was
right when he started the uncensored
site right right he was doing really
well for himself and so his team was
talking to us and he had been trying to
convince me like you need to do an
x-rated pay site
right but dude he had like i would see
on twitter people saying dude vitali i'm
trying to i can't cancel subscription
i'm trying to cancel my subscription and
it won't let me like it was like
that that also makes me glad that i
didn't do that then because okay so the
company's trying to get us to like do
maybe like an x-rated version of the
podcast or whatever and so me and my
girl are talking about it with them and
everything and like over time we start
to be like well what the [ __ ] are we
going to give them a big percentage of
it when we could do all this [ __ ]
ourselves like we know how to hire
filmers we know how to promote we know
how to you know like really we couldn't
really think of that much that they were
going to be bringing to the table and
they were put they were pushing us to go
in more of like a lighthearted like
just show the nipples while we're doing
the interview thing and i'm like that's
cool but realistically
i think that there's a direction that
this is going that like people pay for
porn people pay for podcasts
somebody's gonna do this eventually me
and you both know that we can do it that
we're comfortable having the
conversations and doing the [ __ ] so
why don't we just go for it and so but
but my mentality on it has kind of grown
even from there where now i think of
plug talk as being this overall like
porn media company where i'm trying to
just like make a bunch of cool content
through it in general like right now
we're trying to figure out another
podcast under our network where it's
basically going to be two dudes who
interview a chick and then they [ __ ]
double team the girl together
so it'll be like kind of a different
spin-off on what me and my girl are
doing so i think that there's probably a
bunch of different stuff that we could
kind of do in this world dude it's epic
i know i was like dude i should put on
pornhub like you know 130 day load and
see like how many downloads it gets and
just see how big the load is yeah i
thought about your
busy
like the the last time i saw you and in
waco
and
i i thought to ask you but i was like i
don't want to you know
in case i slipped and it was better
it felt like kind of personal like no
that's cool i mean i went on a date last
weekend and it was it was cool like i'm
i'm i got to go on like 10 dates before
i sleep with a chick to like really get
to know somebody that's the rule you've
given yourself
i mean i would like three dates but like
you know i'm in consultation with
somebody and they're like you know
dating plan get to know them and
maybe go to like six to ten dates before
you start engaging sexual because like
my problem is if if i sleep with them on
the first night the sex is really good
and there's just all these red flags
that i'm ignoring and i'm but the sex is
so good i want more then i'm in this
[ __ ] like toxic
cycle with this person you know it's
worse than that because you're you're
attracted to the toxic yeah so like
that's
i prefer the toxic i respect that
because
looking back on my life there was a
bunch of dudes i knew in my life who
were very selective about who they would
give dick to like they were just they
were like good looking guys or guys the
girls liked and they just decided like
no i'm gonna have girlfriends or when i
do [ __ ] a girl randomly it's only gonna
be because i really like her or i really
think she's super hot or whatever and i
went the total opposite way where i was
i was like amazon like i'll [ __ ] any
we'll sell anything i was like [ __ ] it
i'm doing it whatever
i just wanted the experience i don't
know i just wasn't worried about [ __ ]
some fat girl that i met at the bar like
all right i'm just gonna do it you know
and when i look back at my life i'm like
clearly it would have been better for me
to be a bit more selective but like at
the end of the day with with you and
your girl like um it's not all just sex
like you guys are like best friends or
friends right yeah i mean like that's
important it's like going hiking
together right banging a different chick
together
it's funny though because it's like you
are dealing with like the extreme the
negative like side of like being overly
sexed kind of like
with what you're talking about whereas
like a lot of times people want to ask
me like if i have that kind of
relationship with it and i'm like
honestly i feel like doing this kind of
content has given me a way healthier
relationship with sex because it's just
totally demystified it where it's like
once once
banging a bunch of chicks at one time is
like your job for the day and it's just
kind of the thing that you're showing up
and doing that totally just removes this
layer of
i don't know like the way sex just seems
like this thing that you just want so
bad and it's it's so exotic and special
and fetishized and a lot of that kind of
goes away once you get used to doing it
as a job
yeah i can imagine i mean it's cool to
see you and lux are like best friends
you know like
like i want that because at the end of
the day the sex is gonna you're not
gonna be
like there's different things that
you're gonna want to be attracted to
you're going to be attracted to
spiritually or emotionally yeah versus
just physically yeah whereas like my
problem is as soon as the like the
physical wears off or like the sexual
i'm just like oh my god i'm over it but
if there's other things that are built
before that i think it's just kind of
you know i don't i don't get in the
relationships for long periods of time
and that's part of the problem right
because as soon as like
like i'm over the sex i'm just like late
right
it's weird for me too now though because
we got a kid
and my girl we want to have another kid
at least one more but then meanwhile my
girl's making all this money on only
fans and we're doing all those content
together and it's like
part of me wants to be like hey
[ __ ] all this [ __ ] like you you could
just chill keep pumping out babies i'll
make the money but then like you know
it's like she's kind of wrapped up with
like her sense of self is wrapped up in
how she looks and she doesn't want to
necessarily just like she's kind of torn
because she's like 30 she's like do i
want to do this porn [ __ ] for another
four years and then have a couple kids
or do i want to have another kid right
now and then
get back to doing more content you know
it's kind of like it's it's weirder for
her whereas for me i could just show up
do it and it is what it is you know like
having babies just put such a stress on
a girl's body
right i read somewhere uh that you're
that your only fans is making a million
a month
is that accurate or no i think my quote
was that in general i make like around a
million a month okay yeah so it was like
it's funny because i feel like every
i've never really like said anything
about how much money i make and
i wanted to say it on this one it was
like a business podcast right and i just
wanted to throw that number out there
and it's not like we are actually like
making that every month or it's like
obviously there's a lot of expenses a
lot of things that go into [ __ ] in
general like anybody can tell you that
their business is not the net amount
that they bring in that month or
whatever yeah
it's shocking
how [ __ ] little remains after all the
overhead and the taxes actually jesus
christ yeah welcome to paying 50 in
taxes yeah it's a whole thing there's a
lot of girls making money on only fans
that weren't making money before and
it's like dude what about all these
chicks that are like making a [ __ ] load
of money like are they paying taxes like
you guys like nobody's telling them to
like
well hopefully they are because for sure
your only fans revenue is being reported
very transparently to the government
once you transfer it into your bank
account yeah but yeah like i mean the
only reason i wanted to say that is
because you know in my world the rap
world it's like rappers feel totally
fine telling you hey i made 200 000 for
playing a show last night or i made 50
000 for doing a walkthrough or i just
dropped this album and i made a million
bucks whatever and it's like as a media
person you're kind of expected to never
do that
and the reality is is that i kind of
like look at the up and coming
generation of youtubers and i want to
like inspire them or at least let them
know what's possible so i i kind of like
felt like aaron that number out and i
just picked that number to just give
like a sort of over simplification but
just because i want these kids to do
youtube videos and [ __ ] to know that
it's like yo if you're making five grand
a month right now i mean there's
possibility like i was in that position
too and i grinded my ass off and built
my business into something way crazier
you know yeah for sure yeah i heard you
guys when i went in there talking about
steve will do it and you know getting
cancelled on youtube but
his overhead doesn't stop you know and
so if part of his youtube he's not
making that much money anymore i mean
the dynamic with steve will do it that's
so fascinating to me is that
here he's
throwing around
so much money
but
that's
his stick you know that like outside of
throwing around so much money like what
content
is he gonna be really putting out so he
got kind of like
i almost think trapped in that lifestyle
of throwing around money because that's
what sort of you know his career is but
the thing with him is that he never made
any money of youtube ads so that was
never a concern in the first place it's
all about merch and then sponsors like
primarily the [ __ ] gambling sponsors
i think is like a huge percentage of his
income and him not having a youtube
channel really shouldn't totally change
that because you still have instagram
tick tock whatever like he could still
make the same content he was making and
just put it on tick tock and facebook
and stuff obviously that's going to be a
compromise because it sucks to lose your
five million subscribers or whatever but
like i really think that if he just like
dedicates himself that he'll be able to
make it so that him having a youtube
channel doesn't really matter but he's
gonna definitely have to be creative and
yeah i mean like i've always felt like
that watching all these people give away
so much money it's like it is inspiring
and it's heartwarming and stuff but then
at the same time you're like
is this work in the long run to make a
youtube video that you make 10 grand on
and you're spending 100 grand in the
video like me just as like a person who
was broke not that long ago i'm just
like i just doesn't make me feel
comfortable right me me too and um i
think that there's different approaches
to it like i look at at david dobrik and
the way that he throws around a lot i
think david dobrik is highly strategic
you know and like every time
david dobrik gives away a car i feel
like it's actually a sponsor giving away
the car i think more often than not yeah
yeah so i just think that david dobrik
is uh considerably more savvy
and uh
and you know not to say that
i mean i just don't know steve will do
it's just a [ __ ] mystery man he's so
fascinating
and i i love the guy
i've always been worried about him as
long as i've known him
just because you have been around long
enough and me to a certain extent too
you've seen so many people make 10
million dollars and then [ __ ] up 10
million dollars so it's like but but
younger people they see somebody making
a million bucks a month or whatever and
they're like oh he's rich and he's gonna
be rich forever right we we know how
easy it is to [ __ ] that up i mean i
haven't really done it but like i've
seen other people do it and i know
what it looks like so that's why i'm so
thankful that i managed to like
grind my ass off through my 20s and
early 30s and then only started to see
success once i already had like eaten
[ __ ] so many times and had the world
just [ __ ] spit in my face so many
times so that by the time i finally
started getting to it
yeah i was
cautious you know right and like we were
saying on your podcast about just not
feeling the need to be uh extravagant in
your lifestyle you know like like just
yeah well i look at the island boys and
like all their tick tocks are videos of
them buying stuff at stores like they
putting out their own videos of just
throwing around like 10 grand to buy
some shoe or whatever it is
what's going to do what's going on give
us an island boys
i feel like they were they're faking
buying stuff i feel like it's all fake
yeah or they'll go to like a rich
person's house and film mad tick tocks
and make it look like they're in this
fancy mansion all day when in reality
they you know i don't know where the
[ __ ] they stay at but yeah those dudes
are they're done
we had them on uh on our podcast oh wow
i didn't even know that yeah i saw him
walk off logan paul's podcast yeah
yeah that was like shortly thereafter
that same podcast where i said the thing
about the million dollars that was the
same one that got me in trouble with the
island boys because he
the dude graham stefan was like
yeah is that their guy graham bensinger
yeah he's a really cool guy and he uh he
he
was doing the thing where he was like
you know the island boys i mean i kind
of think that they're like viral
geniuses and i was like no they're
idiots they're like the dumbest
[ __ ] i ever met and then they
saw it which somehow in my head at that
moment i felt like oh i'm i'm talking to
another white guy it's like there's no
hip hop people watching this i can say
whatever i want i can be totally honest
and then wow right i mean yeah that's
that it's it's kind of like saying that
ashley simpson was a
a genius for all the publicity she got
getting caught lip syncing on saturday
night live right yeah people love to lay
that motive down and be like oh look
they were trying to make this happen
people love the idea of conspiracies
rather than just acknowledging that like
a lot of things are random and if they
happen in a specific order then
odd results might occur or or things
that are beneficial might occur because
like i had a dude like basically try to
rob me and like stick a gun in my face i
and and everybody thought it was fake
because i didn't get shot and then what
do i do afterwards i go and do logan
paul's podcast and i'm on the news and i
get all these positive things happen
from it so people thought i had to have
made it up because nothing bad happened
from it and it's like no i was just
taking advantage of the opportunity did
you see your life flash before your eyes
when that happened because you looked
and you thought it was it was like three
seconds so i didn't really have time to
think of anything besides like is this a
joke like that's what i thought like
[ __ ] joke i thought it might have
been one of my friends [ __ ] with me i
heard about that
and then like and i'm like driving to
come see him like like i said i was uh
typed in adam 22 documentary
you know when you scroll through the
youtube feed like without actually
clicking on the video it'll like play it
in place yeah
i one of the one of the videos did and
like the little section of the the video
that played in the feed was you reacting
to the guy with the gun on you right and
and i thought to myself man
like it's so crazy how the
instinct kind of takes over to like put
your hand out like that you know this is
not a good way to stop a bullet yeah
like well that's how you know it's
self-defense when they're doing like the
first 48 because there's bullets through
the hand like it's like right right it's
just like they're really because that's
your reaction
wounds are more like from knives and
stuff but yeah
but yeah it's crazy how your instinct is
to put your hand up to stop a bullet
yeah it's uh it's not it's definitely
changed a lot
and and then and then and and seeing
that i thought man like
like how would i
respond like i got to believe i would
like it just anybody would would react
the same way like just like
you know the natural
it occurs to me that there's no cool
there's no way to look cool when someone
pulls a gun on here
and imagine if i got my [ __ ] head
blown off what that clip would have been
like
it would have been the craziest [ __ ]
thing that might have ever happened on
the internet of like seeing a [ __ ]
influencer get their heads shot up on
like on live stream like that almost
happened and also the other part of why
it was so crazy is because by the time
the guy is near me
the guy who was doing security for us
has his gun out and basically hasn't
pointed out the guy's head now why he
didn't pull the trigger
very controversial but
whatever he had the gun pointed at him
so i'm kind of like feeling like i'm
about to get murdered and then also
feeling like i'm about to see this guy
get murdered so there was so much going
through my head and then somehow it
ended up with him just getting stomped
out and yeah
did that go to court or anything or that
just got handled on the side so yeah the
cops ended up coming they [ __ ] scrape
them up off the ground and take them
away and at one point you know i get
contacted where they're like
you we want you to come to court
and i'm thinking about it and i'm like i
had just been talking to logan paul who
i don't know why i've said his name
three times in the last like five
minutes but i was talking to him and he
told me about the situation he's like my
advice
press charges because he had like one
dude like pull up to his crib like 10
times or some [ __ ] like like when i went
to logan paul's house he had [ __ ]
security outside like he's not [ __ ]
around at all because he's had crazy
fans show up so many times he told me
he's like when it comes down to it press
charges because otherwise this
[ __ ] is going to keep coming
back so i'm like all right that makes
sense so then when they tell me to go to
court i'm like i'm not gonna blow this
off i'm actually gonna go i had to wake
up at like 5 30 in the morning so i
could be downtown at like 7 30 or
whatever and then i'm sitting in the
courtroom i see the [ __ ] kid he's
like sitting a few rows in front of me
with his dad his dad is giving me a
dirty look as if i did something to him
and then
whatever like we're sitting there
eventually the [ __ ] court appointed
lawyer or whoever the [ __ ] it was comes
over and just basically tells me like
hey this is this is postponed so you
don't have to do anything i'm like oh
and they're like
and we're not going to call you back
like we don't need your help anymore i'm
like why this is the dumbest thing ever
i should have just [ __ ] ignored this
like i would have done dude it's crazy
so that he could
attempted murder is that the charge but
it was a fake gun
oh [ __ ] that was a crazy part yeah
like when someone someone mentioned that
to me and yeah they said that this viral
video of someone pulling a gun on adam
22 and that they described it as it
being like super beneficial to you like
that being the point at which you really
blew up ah i mean honestly that was a
couple years after like the soundcloud
rapper wave which is when i first really
blew up is like i interviewed uh xxx
centacion and laura
peep and all these people who just
became [ __ ] gigantic like around that
time that was when like things really
started going crazy this was a couple of
years later and again like it was kind
of convenient because the business and
everything was slowing down a little bit
around that time it wasn't necessarily
as huge as it was like maybe a year
before and it did like bring a ton of
attention but also it was like you get a
lot of attention like that month and
then like the next month you're like
back to normal like that kind of [ __ ]
when you go super viral for something
how many of those people are going to
actually be like tuned in to watch your
[ __ ] every week like
best case scenario you have that kind of
thing happen to you and you can maintain
and like capture a bunch of that
audience but that's why when people were
like thinking it was fake i'm like you
really think that
i would fake that and risk my reputation
of being and be known as a liar forever
for what for like maybe five or ten
grand extra on youtube ads that month
like that doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
yeah it's uh i've always felt super
strongly about not faking [ __ ] and you
just read like that's
from what i saw just that that like you
said three seconds and i saw it like i
was just repeating that three seconds
that red very real dude yeah
you're not you're not faking it like
that you know i mean why would somebody
i even respect the [ __ ] out of it that
you've got that footage of like yeah
this is how like that that it's so real
i almost finished because like okay that
what we were doing is like when there
was a youtube adpocalypse in 2018. i
don't know if you were here really but
i was already like
like not bad friendly right but we like
i i remember right when that happened i
was making maybe like 50 grand a month
off youtube just putting out so much
[ __ ]
and all of a sudden it became five grand
a month and that's when i was like oh
[ __ ] like i gotta actually figure out
all these other revenue streams that i
haven't really like touched on yet like
we gotta start being more serious about
merch and we got to be more serious
about like i i had heard about people
streaming and i was like well maybe i
can just stream and so i start streaming
and then people start being like yo
here's 10 bucks listen to my song and
i'm like all right well he gave me 10
bucks i gotta listen to a song that like
spiraled out of control to the point
where i was like all right i got to
charge more i started charging like 50
or 75 to 100 bucks like to listen to
their song and it just kept coming in
and all of a sudden i was making like
almost 100 grand a month off just
listening to people's music on live
stream like 100 bucks at a time which
that is a thousand songs a month which
sounds [ __ ] kind of depressing to
listen to that many [ __ ] random
soundcloud rap songs but that was what
saved me when the adpocalypse happened
and that's exactly what i was doing when
the guy came in with the gun as i was
sitting in the back of the store with a
couple people smoking blunts and
watching [ __ ] uh people's music
so that dude the music game is crazy i
just met up with the guy that signed the
record deal and he was like dude every
time my song gets played on the radio
anywhere around the world that make 40
bucks
that's what he said that doesn't sound
right i don't know if he's full of [ __ ]
but
it sounds like more like
maybe every time a radio station plays
it they've like now acquired the the
song in their library maybe for every
radio station that that takes off i
don't know
but i never heard anything like that but
maybe i don't know yeah now on your
instagram uh bio it says you're a rapper
yeah it's a joke yeah
let me ask you this did you
were you ever familiar with my
attempt at becoming a rapper oh i do
remember this yeah what year are we
talking 2007 yeah yeah okay
a lot of people have a fire dude a lot
of people tried to become a rapper at
some point
yeah a lot of people you know now i'm
going after a little bit of rap
redemption yeah oh you're gonna do it
again yeah i'm gonna like i i want to
like make some funny rap songs i mean
your your vocal texture i would describe
as gravely yeah and i think that's
that's something the rap rewards from
time to time is that you'll have
somebody like dmx coming
right people like that you know people
want to listen to a cement grinder yeah
a man whose lungs are made of cement
do you have a do you have a top five
favorite rapper
um i mean i have like a pretty
boring top five rappers of all time list
that's pretty close to like everybody
else's where like the only differences
might be that like you know i like i
love cam'ron he was huge for me i love
50 cent i kind of feel like my top five
is like lacking if i'm not honest about
those two
and uh i feel like tupac
and and nas and jay-z
like people i was like i love biggie i
feel like he gets kind of bumped out of
my top five at a certain point but yeah
it's not it's not that interesting when
you really like i don't know why but
it's like there hasn't been that many
rappers that you could really put in
that upper echelon i think in the last
10 or 20 years besides maybe like a
kendrick lamar or
j cole but they're not like my favorite
rappers even though i respect the [ __ ]
out of them
have you had 50 on no jumper no i would
love to that would be amazing i did yeah
i only [ __ ] with white people
all right or at least not me i'm not
this specific white person did you ever
see when he threw me down the stairs in
the bellhop cart i do remember that yeah
yeah
yeah that kind of reminded me of like i
was just watching him with bryce hall uh
doing a tick tock in bryce hall's
backyard and they're kind of like
dancing around together and i'm like
every once in a while 50 you'll come out
and do some content with a white guy
yeah
yeah i wish i could talk to 50 on here
man that would be so great yeah he's
very sparing with his public appearances
you know yeah he's one of them
um so now
with uh
all the the feuds and the [ __ ] beefs
and the crazy like
you've found yourself kind of parked
right in the middle of of crazy beefs
fair to say yeah
been a bit of that
i was saying on your podcast how i was
impressed by the way you kind of
diffused and moderated the the lil xan
beef with his manager right
like uh
and it seems like like you weigh in
you know
pretty objectively on under like you
know if you're talking about like the
island boys or
this and that like
you're like you're not afraid to to call
it the way you see it and maybe ruffle
some feathers yeah i mean you have to
kind of pick and choose your battles
because it's like
if i were to just be totally honest
about everything then i'd be like that
would be just so detrimental to a lot of
my relationships and [ __ ] like you know
like or or even just this like let's be
real 99
of rap music that comes out is
completely a complete failure like it
doesn't sell well it doesn't really
gather much of a fan base it doesn't go
anywhere and i'm even talking about
music coming out of labels and like you
know [ __ ] that like how you have a
reason to think that it would be popular
and the reality is is that like the rap
game produces like a couple of stars a
year maybe if you expand your scope
maybe like a dozen or a couple dozen
people like rise to fame and rap every
year and so me having a platform
i could very easily just let the world
know every rapper i don't like and just
say uh i heard this girl the other day
19 year old chick from baltimore she's
doing her thing shit's trash you know
that that would be me being honest
but i mean there's a certain time where
like being honest is not really like
gonna be good for yourself or the world
like i feel like i would rather do an
interview with that girl who's got a
little something popping off in her
career and like try to support her and
help her even if i don't personally love
the music you know like but there's a
lot of youtube channels who they kind of
solely exist to be like so and so put
their album out it sold 7 000 copies
first week here's why they fell off and
their career is over and they're going
to be sleeping under a bridge soon and
i'm like dude that [ __ ] is kind of like
low-hanging fruit where it's cool that
you're doing it because somebody's got
to do it but i feel like as a content
creator i want to mostly be putting good
things into the world right yeah like
how many youtube videos do you see where
the title is like this rapper can't uh
understand that his career is dying or
yeah you take any person any celebrity
and you put a v you make a video that's
all called the rise and fall of kodak
black it's it's a couple million views
no problem the rise and fall of stevo
boom
doesn't matter that he kind of fell and
then rose again like and sometimes
they'll put that in the title right and
rose again but like yeah i mean it's
it's the easiest kind of thing to get
views on is just to make a video that is
like critical of somebody who's widely
beloved
yeah or just critical of anyone people
love to just hear people [ __ ] on other
people you know what are your what are
your thoughts on charlemagne the god
i interviewed him back in the day he's
definitely probably like one of the
people who's
shown us the heights that you can reach
through
being like a
hip-hop media personality for sure just
seeing them do all this crazy tv stuff
and everything like
i mean
as somebody who's been watching them for
like 10 years i definitely did not know
that he had that in him but it's it's
definitely an inspiration for sure yeah
yeah i mean he's an impressive cat yeah
yeah well i like what he's doing
for mental health too
like that like i guess he somebody was
telling me that he just came out and
said dude i i go to therapy like if you
have problems go get help go get on ssr
whatever you know and don't keep that
[ __ ] in and like he's all about
encouraging people to like work that
[ __ ] out which i think is [ __ ]
massively i think he's a good
good at like sort of finding that line
of like being honest not like [ __ ]
blowing smoke up anyone's ass yeah and
like just
you know but he had to kind of like
leave a lot of the edgy [ __ ] in the past
you know because his thing
was always just saying the craziest [ __ ]
to people and just making them react you
know like he said to [ __ ] post malone
he said what are you doing to support
black lives matter at the very beginning
of post malone's career post malone like
obviously kind of bumbled his answer a
little bit i don't think he said
anything like super offensive but like
you know he would love to do that like
he would always be making people walk
out on him and [ __ ] and it's it has been
kind of interesting to see him like
fall back on that [ __ ] a little bit and
be a little bit more of just like a a
good interviewer you know you think
because the birdman [ __ ] came in
there was just like yo no i think he
doesn't want to get canceled i think
that charlemagne at a certain point
decided that he doesn't want to make the
woke people angry and he sort of fell in
line to a certain extent but i mean i
still i still respect it you know it's
like it's not for everybody to be edgy
for the rest of your career you know
sure he has kamala harris who's really
running the country and she acted like
she didn't hear him and she just dipped
yeah and in moments like that you are
like okay that's the old charlemagne
right there giving her a hard time yeah
she was classic with six nine
you know and that wasn't being edgy that
was just being like about six nine ran
[ __ ] circles around him in those
interviews that that actually was when i
realized how powerful of a communicator
69 was that i've always compared him to
donald trump in the sense that like he
just
is the biggest piece of [ __ ] but he can
just control the room and everybody's
attention you know and i when i saw 69
like not the first interview but the
second interview that he did on
breakfast club which as far as i could
tell is like the biggest rap interview
ever because on youtube because i went
and looked
because i was trying he said um he only
fears uh the feds yes but i i went and
looked to see if it was the biggest
rapper interview of all time because i
thought my xxx centasy on interview
might have the most views of any rapper
new ever on youtube but i think that one
has a little bit more but either way
like when you watch that interview like
charlemagne normally controls the room
in his interviews and six nine is like
he's just running [ __ ] in that interview
and like they have three hosts and
they're kind of like powerless to stop
the energy of like what he was bringing
to that room you know and like that
doesn't exist anymore i've noticed
because i watched like other six nine
interviews since then like since he
snitched and got off on the fed case or
whatever and it's
it's not the same like he's just he
doesn't have the same charm that he had
before all that but i i mean when he was
at his heights it was insane but when he
was in that one interview recently where
he was just like yelling like is he
lacking like i don't even you know and
yeah but he the reason why he controlled
the room was because he was just like
loud and aggressive and like what do you
do today but in that recent one that
you're talking about i think with uh
it's it's like academics whack 100 yeah
who's saying uh hassan campbell and then
him and it's like he's got some of his
like brooklyn goons like his gang
members that he's rolling around with
and everyone else is talking over him
it's like he just clearly doesn't
command the same like social status that
he had before so people aren't just
seating the floor to him in the
conversation that whole like godly
thing that he had going on is gone which
is pretty [ __ ] crazy to me to just
watch that obs to observe that just sort
of like dissipate over time what's
lacking mean lacking is like if you're
outside without a gun and somebody runs
up on you and robs you and you were
lacking and then what's the stand tall
guy a standard he's talking stand up guy
he was like you know he was pakistan
tall guy
he said
i'm like what i don't even know what
these means i don't know probably just
like maybe somebody that has a gun i
would think you're saying like basically
that
you have a gun and if somebody runs up
on you and tries to disrespect you
you're going to shoot them that type of
thing because i think they were talking
about the situation with meek mill where
69 like ran up on meek mill outside a
club in miami right and like six nine
had security meek mill had security meek
mill has retired cops or like off-duty
cops with guns and everything and six
nine
basically gets in his face and just
yells at him and disrespects him and
says a bunch of crazy [ __ ] and meek
basically was like [ __ ] like he yelled
back for a bit but then he was like [ __ ]
this and he walked off and
avoided the situation you know which is
to a lot of like gang members and stuff
they use this as like evidence that meek
mill's a [ __ ] because he refused to
you know do battle with six nine in this
situation which to me is like a person
who's more concerned with not going to
prison i'm like
i think meek mill did what he [ __ ]
was supposed to do i mean you got all
the security around you for a reason so
you don't have to entertain these
[ __ ] morons right right if a guy
comes up to me right now in the parking
lot and says hey man i'm tougher than
you boom bam boom whatever it's like
that's why i have a [ __ ] security
guard right over there so that i don't
have to listen to your dumb ass opinions
crazy and if you want to act tough or
you want to pull a gun out then he's
going to shoot you and
lol you know
oh wow
dad that's that that's insane man that's
insane what a fascinating [ __ ]
conversation dude yeah i really enjoyed
it yeah
yeah dude and thank you so much dude i
appreciate i was just watching you with
um bert yeah just randomly i watched
that episode because i was being kind of
interested in him and you know what
really got me is he mentioned how uh him
and uh what's his name chris uh that he
does the other podcast with
tom segre tom segura nobody has another
one with a that he was doing with the
dude chris destefano i think his name is
chris
is that his name yeah um and they
started talking about their kids and
they started talking about like the the
compromise of being on the road all the
time as a comic and
and and missing out on so much of your
kids [ __ ] and they start crying their
eyes out in the conversation and boom
i'm [ __ ] crying my my eyes out your
podcast is to the left of it paused i'm
watching this clip and i'm just [ __ ]
like getting it i'm like wow this is
[ __ ] this says a lot about podcasts
and that these two [ __ ] are
sitting here having a conversation with
their kids crying their eyes out and
they got me sitting here at home like
six months after it came out watching it
and i'm doing the same exact thing
i mean that that to me i was like this
is a beautiful medium right here it is
dude yeah
yeah it's unbelievable i know when i
looked you up because i was like man
this guy i always see you on tick tock
and i've been following you for a couple
years but then i'm like how old are you
and we're the same age i've always loved
seeing people the same age as me like
killing it and like you know i see like
uh
like shia labeouf me and him are the
same age it's like you know cause like
we grew up in the same era it's like
dude you made it sick and i'm always
like stoked on you when i see you
because me coming from like the bmx
world and like i'm sure you guys would
say the same thing is that like when
when you're younger and you see people
around you getting successful
it can be kind of like you feel like oh
[ __ ] like like like all the bmx dudes i
would see were like getting sponsored
and they're on covers and magazines and
[ __ ] i'm like looking at them like
they're the [ __ ] man and i wasn't
good at bike riding like that i just
loved the community and the culture and
everything and you know to be able to
like actually see some heights in my
career like this late into it i
definitely don't take that [ __ ] for
granted for sure and i mean i think
about it all the time like even when i
was listening to them cry and have that
conversation about missing their kids
growing up because they're on the road
making six figures for a tour or
whatever it's like they even said it's
like there's a lot of people who are
missing their kids growing up
to just what like do construction 80
hours a week just just to make sure that
their kid has a little bit better
opportunity than they have
i mean that's some real [ __ ] right there
you know
dude
yeah and so like
you
are gonna be a part of your kids life
because all you gotta do is go in the
studio and bang a couple chicks i know
right
and then the only hard part is that i
got to explain that to my kid one day
dad thank you so much no no doubt i
really appreciate it thank you so much
you did for sure you guys are awesome uh
congrats on all the success on youtube
and with podcasts and everything yeah
likewise appreciate that dude
cool man sorry i got some [ __ ] hot in
here man dude
do you want to cut anything
ah my beloved street team i'm so excited
that i'm doing this as a collab with my
man adam22
check out the podcast i did with him
right
yeah here
yeah dear how have i never done an end
screen dude i love you guys thank you
for sticking around
do you think i got like three more
seconds if i can [ __ ] yeah